thank
is
thank you so much
i know
uh
the wall
all right
i will tell you masks are a little
tricky with earrings on so just bear
with me here
okay let's have a couple of items at the
top
okay learn my lesson on earrings all
right
today the president will deliver remarks
to mark the 50
mark 50 million shots that have been
administered since he entered
office in his remarks he will provide an
update on the strong progress we've made
across our pandemic response to date
he will commend the covert response
team's extraordinary whole of government
effort
to get shots in the arms of americans as
well as the work of so many americans
who have stepped up to the plate in this
moment
he will also remind americans that now
is not the time to let our guards down
especially in the face of new variants
he will continue
he will encourage people to continue
wearing a mask and get vaccinated
when it is their turn i also have some
brief updates on the winter storm that
affected a few states
last week as many of you saw last night
the president approved the state of
oklahoma's major disaster declaration
request
this action will authorize fema to
provide both public and individual
assistance including grants for
temporary housing
and home repairs low-cost loans to cover
uninsured property losses
and other programs to help individuals
and business owners recover from the
effects of the disaster
power and water restoration continue
across texas louisiana and oklahoma
accelerated vaccine shipments are
occurring and vaccination appointments
are being rescheduled
and expanded to accommodate those
cancelled last week
and as you all know the president is of
course traveling to texas tomorrow
today the vice president also visited a
local giant pharmacy in washington dc
that is participating in the amer
administration's federal retail pharmacy
program
the program is increasing access to
coven 19 vaccines across the country
the biden harris administration is
committed to ensuring
americans have access to vaccine in
their own communities including
at local pharmacies and last week alone
the administration doubled
our allocation to pharmacies to over 2
million doses across
7 000 pharmacies with that darlene
why don't you kick it off great i have a
question to start off with about nira
tandon
um so when she tweeted that quote a
vampire has more heart than ted cruz
when she compared senator mcconnell to
voldemort
and when she called senator collins
quote the worst
digital's comments meet the president's
standard of treating everyone with
dignity and respect
well first i'll note that when nira
tandon testified
just a few weeks ago she apologized for
her past comments
and that she would be joining an
administration whereas we've noted in
here
there's an expectation of a high bar of
civility
and engagement whether that's on social
media or in person and we certainly
expect
she would meet that bar did the
president and the transition team
underestimate how much of a problem her
tweets would become
the president nominated nira tandon
because she is qualified
because she's experienced because she
has a record of working with people who
agree with her and disagree with her
with and she has decades of experience
and plus she has lived experience
of her own having benefited from a
number of the programs that she would
oversee
as a daughter of a single parent and
somebody who
benefited from food stamps at certain
points in time she would bring a new
perspective to the role
that's why he nominated her to the job
and why we're continuing to fight
uh for her confirmation on the 50
millionth
shot this afternoon does the white house
is the white house able to say
where and when that shot was
administered what state
even some characteristics about who may
have received it yeah
it's a great question i think the
challenge is that we get data in from so
many different sources on a daily basis
from states from pharmacies
from mass vaccination sites that we um
we hit that point the hit the 50
millionth shot
uh sometime yesterday if not a little
bit before but we can't fine-tune
exactly the person
who hit that point hit that shot thank
you
sure go ahead any update on the
president's phone call or
scheduled phone call with queen salman
saudi arabia i don't have an update
as i noted yesterday as soon as that
call happens we expect it to be very
soon
uh we will of course provide a readout
to all of you you said when they do talk
that the president
won't hold back will he be following up
this talk with actions are sanctions on
the table
i think there are a range of actions
that are on the table but
the first step is the next step i should
say is for the president to speak with
the king we expect that to happen very
soon
as you know we've committed to the
release of an unclassified report that
would come out from
dni and not from the white house and of
course
our administration is focused on
recalibrating the relationship as we've
talked about in here previously
and certainly there are areas where we
will express concerns
and leave open the option of
accountability there are also areas
where we will continue to work with
saudi arabia
given the threats they face in the
region what's the hold up to the phone
call
is the king avoiding your calls i i
don't think that's the characterization
the president has a busy schedule
the king obviously uh i can't speak to
his schedule i'm not his spokesperson
but
we expect the call to happen very soon i
think there was some inaccurate
reporting about it being confirmed when
it wasn't a confirmed call yet
and you have made clear that the
president is going to be speaking with
his counterpart with the king not with
the crown prince
but given the crown prince's role in the
future of the kingdom and that he is
expected to be implicated here
why not speak to the person expected to
be responsible
well i think the president's
conversation will cover a range of
topics with the king there's obviously
a lot to discuss with saudi arabia and
with the leaders of saudi arabia and
as i noted i've previously noted uh the
the crown prince has
been engaged with his appropriate
counterparts uh the president will be
engaged with his appropriate
counterparts and we're engaged at many
levels
uh with leaders in saudi arabia so will
the crown prince's counterparts here
what austin he's speaking to him about
this issue though he spoke with him
last week they did a readout i don't
think i have anything more about uh
their call
to read out uh go ahead all right thank
you i just wanna ask what the post
office a couple of questions
he said earlier today that there was
concerns i guess
with the the leadership but it's clear
that the leadership can do better and so
that's our hope
you clarify what do you want to change
in the postmatch in general now that
you've named
new members to the board secondly
they've announced the purchase of a new
fleet
the president of course announced on
january 27th to study
uh pursued aiming at electrifying the
government's lead including the post
office
uh only ten percent of the fleet
dividends they're buying will be elected
you plan to change that order or see
changes to it at all
sure uh the second question i'll have to
follow up on more specifics on it that
is certainly something the president's
committed to
i don't have an update on it but i can
venture to get one for you
on the first question some people may
not be following this as closely as you
and i have so let me just give a little
more context uh
of course the president is committed to
the post office the postal service's
success
which is why yesterday he nominated
three extremely qualified individuals
to fill the empty spots on the board of
governors
anton hajjar amber mcreynolds and ron
strowman
and the american people highly value the
postal service and the men and women who
deliver our
mail every day and we're working hard to
do exactly that
but i think we can all agree most
americans would agree
that the postal service needs leadership
that can and will do a better job now
as you know uh and but not everybody
knows
it's up to the board of governors of
which we just nominated
three individuals to serve to determine
the future of leadership there and we
certainly leave it up to their
discretion
sounds like you're signaling that the
board could take a look at it
does the president have confidence in
the current books
i think the president is certainly
familiar with the process he believes
the leadership can do better and
uh we're eager to have the board of
governors in place
a slightly separate subject you may have
seen that gamestop
is spiking again as are similar stocks
or
stocks there i call them do you have
views on whether
the fcc or the administration the
treasury secretary will weigh in
if we continue to see these sort of mean
stocks fluctuating and fighting like
this
well as you know um the sec had uh had
been
uh had had over has oversight i should
say and certainly has been
watching it closely monitoring closely
the treasury secretary also convened a
meeting
just a few weeks ago but i would
certainly send you to them on what their
plans are for
monitoring engagement or speaking to it
since that meeting
i would send you directly to them to
give any update on
their progress and how they're
monitoring it sure go ahead uh
president is going to texas tomorrow um
he's obviously going to show empathy for
the
victims of the storm does he have a
message for the leadership
in texas on how to better prepare for
winter storms and
what can the federal government do to
kind of coerce private industry
there to to better prepare well let me
first say that he'll be traveling for
the most of the day with the governor um
and he'll be
they'll be surveying the damage and i'm
sure he'll be getting an update and
briefings from him directly
president doesn't view the crisis and
the millions of people have been
impacted by it as a
democratic or republican issue he views
it as an issue where he's eager to
get relief to tap into all the resources
in the federal government to make sure
the people of texas
know we're thinking about them we're
fighting for them and we're going to
continue working on this as they're
recovering
there's plenty of time to have a policy
discussion about
better weatherization better
preparations and i'm sure that's one
that will be had but
right now we're focused on getting
relief to the people in the state
uh getting updated briefings tapping
into all of the levers of federal
government
there's a lot of hearings uh on the hill
about how the capitol police responded
or
prior to the january 6 events
mike pence and his family were there
that day
secret service had intelligence
briefings presumably
is there any concern or review about how
the secret service
assessed intelligent briefings and
whether there was any missteps on their
part
uh review by the secretary
mike pence and his family were at
capitol hill that day um clearly there
was
intelligence out there that suggested
things could happen and curious to
whether there's been any
any review by the secret service or
ordered
uh about the secret service action that
day um
and they're how they handle it i i'd
encourage you to reach out to the
leadership of the secret service
to get a further comment on it um go
ahead kristen i'll come tune in
thank you jim a little bit of
housekeeping on the texas questions if i
could
will president biden invite senator cruz
and
cornyn to texas with them to travel in
air force one
well uh dr biden is traveling of course
uh with
us uh to uh to texas with the president
of texas there are some limitations on
space available so there are not members
i don't believe i will double check on
this
of any party traveling with the
president to texas
but again he's going to be spending the
day traveling with governor abbott and
surveying the damage on the ground will
they be a part of
his plans to survey the damage will they
join him in any of those events tomorrow
has there been any invitation extended
uh i'm happy to follow up on it uh for
you kristen but i'm not aware of their
plans to participate in the events
tomorrow but i can check
okay i want to ask you about the uptick
in migrants at the border
um some members of the democratic party
are displeased
with the way the administration is
handling children who are being held at
the border alexandria casio cortez
tweeted this quote this is not okay
never has been okay
never will be okay no matter the
administration or
party is this a failure on the part of
this administration
well first i can't speak to what this is
that is being referred to
children in these detention facilities
well that's not what's happening
uh and you know we will be doing some
briefings of course with members of
congress but what is happening now is
there are
children uh fleeing prosecution
fleeing uh threats in their own
countries
traveling on their own unaccompanied to
the border
and our focus is on approaching this
from the view of humanity and from
and with safety in mind and so the steps
that we have taken is
they are of course processed as quickly
as possible
ideally with a maximum of three days
through cbp
then they are transferred to facilities
overseen by hhs
we had to open reopen a new facility uh
that had previously been closed because
of covid protocols
because previously because we can't have
kids in beds next to each other we need
space appropriate it's been revamped
there are there's educational services
there there are
there are health services and medical
services but our objective is to move
them
as quickly as we can to families that
have been vetted
and to of course reunite kids with their
families
who says she sees these images and it's
not okay from her perspective
well look uh we will work of course with
congresswoman ocasio-cortez on a range
of issues and we look forward to doing
that what i'm
conveying from here is what the actual
circumstances on the ground
and uh the tough choice that we have had
to make there are only a couple of
options here so
either we send kids back to a very
dangerous journey
back to their countries that's not a
good option i don't think anyone would
support that option
we send them to families that have not
been vetted we've seen challenges with
that in the past where kids have then
been trafficked
that is not a good option in our view
our best option in our view
is to get these kids processed through
hhs facilities
where there are coveted protocols in
place where they are safe where they
can have access to educational and
medical care there are no there are very
few good options here and we chose the
one we thought was best
i just want to ask you about cpac i know
you got some questions about this
yesterday if i could try again
based on our reporting former president
trump is
going to be talking about president
biden's immigration
policies he will point to the uptick in
migrants
coming to the u.s how is the
administration planning to respond
well we're not looking to former
president trump or any of his advisors
as a model for how we're approaching
immigration
in fact we're in the circumstance we're
in because
not only was their approach inhumane it
was ineffective
and so we're going to forge our own path
forward we'll see
what he says but our focus is certainly
not what on president trump is saying at
cpac
go ahead thank you jan uh the head of
the group the president is going to meet
with today the national governors
association andrew cuomo is being
accused of
sexual harassment by a former staffer
named lindsey boylan she says that cuomo
while he was governor gave her an
unwanted kiss on the lips he asked her
to play strict
poker is the white house worried about
this becoming a distraction from
an important meeting about toby response
well let me first say that the president
has been consistent
in his position when a person comes
forward they deserve to be treated with
dignity and respect their voice should
be heard not silenced
and any allegations should be reviewed
governor cuomo
is also the governor of one of the
largest states in the country
that has been one of the hardest hit
with millions of people still suffering
from an ongoing pandemic and an economic
crisis
and our focus is to continue working
with governors from across the country
from a range of states on how we're
helping people in their states he also
is still head of the national governors
association hence he's
at the event today and to him being in
charge of the governors and
in charge of such a big state will the
president
uh talk to him about these accusations
from democrats in
the new york legislature that cuomo
misled the public about
deaths in nursing homes throughout the
pandemic well this is a
meeting and a conversation with a range
of governors about how we can all
work together to address the pandemic
and get relief to the american people
and that's what i expect the focus of
the meeting to be on
there are some democrats in new york who
want a but who want congressional
hearings about these debts in nursing
homes there was a
cuomo aide who told lawmakers in
february
that the cuomo administration withheld
the number of residents who died in
hospitals
from the public due to the fear that it
would be used against them by federal
prosecutors
is this something the white house thinks
would be appropriate for
a congressional hearing it's really up
to congress to determine
how they want to review or have hearings
on those reports and i know you were
asked about this this weekend but i'll
try again
uh does president biden still think
andrew cuomo
is the gold standard for copen
leadership and that he's doing a hell of
a job
which he has said about him well
first of all i think to be fair let's
put all the comments in context which
sometimes is a missing from these
conversations we have in here or during
interviews
at the time which was i believe april of
last year
the president spoke out and said
positive things about a range of
governors democrats and republicans who
were stepping in when there was a vacuum
of leadership
at the federal level when they were
getting no information when they were
getting no help and no guidance
from the former trump administration he
had he made some positive comments about
uh governor cuomo and his role in new
york at the time as he did about a range
of
governors okay and then one more on
climate change
there's been some reports about a
meeting with airline ceos
next week how important is it to the
white house to reduce airline
emissions as part of an overall climate
agenda
i'm not actually familiar with that
meeting do you know who is with
gina mccarthy and some of the airline
companies ceos
i'd have to look back into it i don't
have any more details on that meeting
i'm happy to uh go ahead thank you just
want to follow up on the unaccompanied
children
is president biden open to the creation
of an ombudsman within the health and
human services department this has been
proposed by
congressional progressive caucus chair
familia
jayapal this person would be able to go
in
and check out the facility to see the
care that that the children are
receiving and report back to congress
uh would would the administration
support such a role within health and
human services
i i have actually not spoken with the
president about that proposal by
congresswoman jayapal
we have i should note i think uh someone
asked us the other day
uh we have had cameras hhs has had
cameras in there also
to uh make sure people in the public the
media are able to see
um the conditions uh in these facilities
and we'd certainly be open to supporting
that in the future but i'd have to
follow up with him and our legislative
team on that proposal those lawmakers
obviously being able to go in
and see the care of the children we
would certainly support that
sure one more question in 2018 it was
discovered migrant children were being
forced to take psychiatric medication
without knowing the drugs they were
taking things like lithium and so on
what's being done obviously these
children need psychiatric care some
cases have been traumatized
they've had a difficult time what can
the administration do to assure that
these kind while the
the children are getting the care they
need there would be no such abuses
well i would say first we are not using
the past management as our guide and
the we have the secretary of homeland
security is of course overseeing uh in
coordination with the
health and human uh health and homeless
sorry hhs secretary it's a mouthful
um to ensure that these children are
treated humanely
they are provided with the medical
assistance they need the mental health
assistance
they need and you're absolutely right i
mean these kids have been through a
trauma
and we want to treat them humanely and
make sure they're kept safe so i would
send you of course to
the hhs team uh to get more specifics of
how it's monitored but
certainly that's our expectation go
ahead in the back
um has the president been following um
brexit and has it
gone as he expected so far um
and does he share the position that uh
president obama expressed in 2016 when
he said
um brexit would put the uk at the back
of the queue for
trade deals with the us well lots
happened on brexit
and in the world since 2016 i think it's
fair to say uh
i will say that president biden is
focused on strengthening our domestic
economy through significant investments
in american workers and competitiveness
that's his focus he's committed to
prioritizing those investments at home
before signing new trade deals
that's his approach and that's how he
sees
trade deals in general around the world
making those investments is critical
to restoring the middle class and making
us more competitive so
our team is still reviewing negotiations
that were begun under the prior
administration
uh ambassador designate tai of course
had her hearing
uh this morning and she will be
essential to that review
has the president spoken to any uh
leaders from africa
yet and how concerned is he about
competition from china
in africa well certainly we've long been
concerned the united states has long
been concerned about competition from
china and africa
we we provide readouts whenever he does
calls with foreign leaders
so he has not quite made it to every
foreign leader at this point in time
but i'm sure that um engagement with
china
and the bar and the we expect to be set
um
would be part of those discus many of
those discussions go ahead thanks john
uh senate budget committee chairman
bernie sanders said this week that he
hope is using reconciliation to pass the
president's infrastructure package
is the president of the other approach
and has you spoken with bernie sanders
about it
that would require having an
infrastructure package right to decide
how it would pass
well let me first say that our focus is
on the american rescue plan
and of course the president has talked
about what his buildback
better agenda would look like on the
campaign trail infrastructure is a part
of it he's been a long fan of investing
in infrastructure
long outdated long overdue i should say
but he also wants to
do more on caregiving help our
manufacturing sector do more to
strengthen access to affordable health
care
so the the size the package the
components of it the order
that has not yet been determined and i
feel like that's the next step
i don't expect the president or any of
us will preview anything until we have
the american rescue plan through
one more uh the chief of staff said
yesterday that the
um president wouldn't overrule the
parliamentarian
if she decides that you can't raise the
minimum wage as part of this broader
economic relief package
if that is the decision what's the next
step on raising the minimum wage does he
expect to
introduce a standalone bill would it be
part of his upcoming economic
broader account well first let me say it
would be a serious step for the vice
president to take that step and
obviously
she and the president respect the uh
historic institution of the senate it
would also require 50 votes
uh so there's it's not just a standalone
step that
any vice president could take uh in
terms of the minimum wage
you know we're still waiting uh for the
conclusion
of the parliamentarian's
view on whether or not the raise in the
minimum wage
should be included can be included i
should say in the american rescue plan
uh that's where the state the step
the process is at this stage in time the
president included an increase in the
minimum wage because he believes it
should be
uh it's a long overdue and american
workers should not be
uh struggling to make ends meet but
that's the next step and
and we'll have to go from there is
the administration considering easing
social distancing rules for an
accomplishment of company minors in
these detention facilities to allow
more unaccompanied minors to to being
in the facility i'm not aware of that
consideration i mean one of the reasons
that we
opened this facility revamped this
facility is because we did not want to
put unaccompanied miners
at risk and we obviously follow cdc
guidelines which is six feet of
separation
so my expectation is we would continue
to follow those guidelines
um go ahead so march 21st is coming up
is the first anniversary of border
restrictions between the us and canada
and mexico
um back in october republicans and
democrats in texas demanded
that the trump administration release a
plan for reopening the order
um these restrictions have obviously
divided families they've devastated the
economy on the border
um is the can we expect a plan from the
vitamin administration anytime soon on
um potential quarterly openings and what
would the parameters for that look like
i do expect there will be more on this
soon
it would likely come from the state
department um so i would send you to
them for an update on the status and the
timeline
go ahead thank you very much jen um i
wanted to ask about the
domestic terrorism review the president
asked for a 100-day domestic terrorism
review he had the
dni take charge of that and work closely
with the fbi
and dhs what does the president expect
to come out of that review at the end of
100 days if you want to see a report
a list of recommendations what is he
expecting to see and what
what would we expect to see out of that
review well we have more than 60 days
left until we hit 100 days
in terms of the format of what the
review will look like
i would expect some form of a report i
don't know yet if it will include
specific recommendations or if it will
then launch a policy process
i can talk to our team and see if
there's more specifics have the
president been briefed and updated on
the progress of that review we're about
33 35 days into it
as you know the president has daily
meetings
as a part of the pdb and certainly
tracking threats to our homeland
is a part of what's discussed there but
i don't have any update for you on
updates on the overall report that's not
due for more than 60 days
and what's the president's assessment
now of the threat from domestic
terrorism
you know we obviously saw domestic
terrorists involved
and groups of armed groups involved in
the january 6th
insurrection in the subsequent weeks
how has that changed well the reason
that he asked
his national security team to do a
comprehensive review was so that he
wasn't
looking at it and we weren't looking at
it through the prism of one event versus
another event or through a political
lens
so i'm not going to be able to offer for
you a day by day or week by week
assessment
we're going to wait for this review to
conclude and then we'll use that as
guidelines for our process and our
policies moving forward
go ahead george thanks man i have a
question for myself and then one for
reporters who can't be here on the
budget new presidents
put their own stamp on on the budget and
all
recent new presidents have given a
speech in february
that talks about the budget and then
within a month or so submitted
uh their revisions uh can you talk about
what
your the president's timetable is given
and how much it's affected by the fact
that the pandemic
the less than cooperative transition and
the failure to confirm a
director sure george well the president
is certainly
looking forward to sharing his budget
priorities for the fiscal year with
congress
and of course the american people as our
nation faces unprecedented challenges
we anticipated during the transition and
we talked about it a bit during the
transition
that the budget would be delayed due to
some intransigence we encountered
from political appointees at omb during
the transition
those roadblocks definitely delayed the
process
we have a strong place in team in place
of course at omb
many of many of whom are career
officials who are working
through administrations to put budgets
together
but the lack of a confirmed head of omb
certainly doesn't help to expedite the
process so we
certainly anticipate it will be delayed
i don't have an exact timeline on it but
i wouldn't expect a budget rollout or
announcement in february to give that
kind of traditional speech or does a
pandemic make that impossible
a traditional budget speech speak to
congress
well i i think we would be looking at a
non-traditional approach to a joint
session i don't have any update
on what that will look like at this
point simply because i don't think
anyone could envision
500 members of congress in there with a
president of the united states during a
pandemic but i don't have any updates on
the timeline or format
one from other reporters is sort of a
follow-up to your
earlier answer when you do
make the declassified the report on
saudis
will that come at the same time as you
announce
any kind of sanctions or actions or is
that a separate timetable for those two
i'm not going to be in a position to
preview that i would just say the
unclassified report would be released
from dni not from the white house
um and i would just broadly remind you
that
oftentimes any actions related to global
issues or don't come out of the white
house they come out of a range of
agencies
but i don't have anything to preview for
you at this point in time uh go ahead
lola
thank you i would like to ask you about
uh india and pakistan today announced
ceasefire along the shared border
including land of control this for the
first time i think after 2003 that they
have
this kind of ceasefire uh what uh what
is how what has to say on this well the
united states welcomes the joint
statement between india and pakistan
that the two countries have agreed to
maintain strict observance of a
ceasefire
along the line of control starting on
february 25th
this is a positive step towards greater
peace and stability in south asia
which is in all shared are is in our
shared interests and we encourage both
countries
to keep building upon this progress
in the fight against terrorism okay
sorry
i'm sorry the masks always make it hard
to hear people on the way back can you
say that one more time
is pakistan doing enough in the fight
against terrorism
well of course we remain closely engaged
with a range of leaders and officials in
the region including those in pakistan
but in terms of an assessment of that i
would point you to the state department
or the intelligence department
yesterday president issued a
proclamation in which he revoked the
previous predecessor's policy on issuing
of new green cards to those people who
are outside the country
there are a lot of legal immigrants who
leave the country and they want to make
this country as their home
but they're having a decade long wait
for the issue of green card so that
once they get it the potential is
unfolded they can
open their company they can have the
startups
and they give employment great
employment generate development in this
country
what's the present message to those
legal immigrants in this country
well the president believes that it's
important
and long overdue to put in place uh
immigration
to modernize our immigration system and
that includes
taking steps to help ensure that high
skilled workers
can stay in the country and can go
through the proper
process to stay in the country so we're
eager to work with democrats and
republicans in congress to get that done
one more final one several republicans
on the hill and
including nikki haley the former u.s
ambassador uh
are urging president biden to uh
not to participate in next week's
chinese winter olympics
has the president taking a decision on
that uh there hasn't been a final
decision made on that and of course we
would uh
look for guidance from the u.s olympic
committee
go ahead thank you jen back on
immigration do you believe that you have
a crisis at the border and
is the government out acting as if you
had a crisis at the border
well certainly um you know having uh
unaccompanied minors uh travel across
the border and
so many that we are looking we had to
open in new facilities is something that
we
uh take incredibly seriously and we um
you know are eager to of course address
humanely
and with the focus of keeping them safe
i don't think i'm going to put new
labels
on it from here or from the podium but
it is a
a priority of the administration it's a
priority of our
secretary of homeland security and
certainly of the presidents who's kept
abreast of the developments
on family reunification the lawyers the
pro bono lawyers that have been working
with the families and trying to get them
together announced yesterday that about
100 families have been reunited
from those 600 kids that were in the
system and lost
has the government been working with
those pro bono lawyers as well to
to get that process going well this
program is being overseen
the family reunification task force by
the department of homeland security by
our secretary of homeland security
of course he will be doing an official
report at about the 120-day mark but i
would send you to them for any updates
or status of our work with those lawyers
texas ruling about the 100-day
moratorium on deportation will the
government appeal to a higher court will
the
legal process continue well uh
let me first say a couple of things
about this because we haven't talked
about this in the last couple of days
the pause of on deportations was a
time to reset our enforcement priorities
so that we focus on threats to national
security and public safety as opposed to
mothers and fathers
who are long-standing members of our
community who are in many cases
performing essential work during the
pandemic so the
department of homeland security has put
in place interim enforcement priorities
and is reviewing the prior
administration's
policies and practices the court's
ruling still
allows us to do this in terms of next
steps
or how we will approach it from here i
would send you to our
department of justice and will the
president address immigration at all
downing texas tomorrow uh the president
will be
um certainly speaking uh
uh you know about uh kovid and
addressing the pandemic
uh he will also be speaking about the um
impact of the storm on the people of the
state uh and
i know immigration is an issue on the
minds of many people there
but i don't have anything to preview in
terms of whether he'll address it while
he's there
go ahead josh i heard the vaccine this
afternoon
the president has made equity a key part
of his response
took a mixed result on that some states
have no data
for instance on race the people
vaccinated other states
the data is showing that white and asian
people are getting the vaccine
disproportionately as compared to black
and latino people
the president think enough is being done
with regards to equitably distributing
the vaccine
the president has always known from the
day he
took office and as has the vice
president that uh
addressing uh ensuring that we equitably
equitably distribute the vaccine would
be
a big challenge because there was a lack
of
accurate data as you referenced because
it is
challenging you have to use a number of
approaches to get into communities where
there is vaccine hesitancy which is an
ongoing issue that we're working to
address
so of course he feels that there is more
that needs to be done
and that there's more of that across his
team he will continue to
encourage people to take action on
now there are a number of steps
including
partnering with community and
faith-based organizations enhancing
public transit options
working of course distributing vaccines
to pharmacies
opening mass vaccination sites that we
are taking as an
administration to more equitably
distribute the vaccine but there's more
work to be done
and we expect as we get to the point
where there are
enough vaccines for americans uh 300
million by the time we get to the end of
july or if not sooner
that one of the challenges will be um
you know ensuring it's equitably
distributed
and that people who are uh have a
history of vaccine hesitancy take the
vaccine
go ahead there are reports that if
congress launches a 911 style commission
to investigate the january
6th insurrection nancy pelosi wanted to
have
seven democrats and four republicans
as part of the makeup would the white
house be satisfied with that or would
you rather see it more evenly
uh distributed by party we leave that up
to
congress uh leaders in congress to
determine what that uh will look like
and on immigration why does the white
house think
there is this surge of unaccompanied
children
right now your critics are saying it's
because you're not sending anybody
back any of these unaccompanied children
back do you share that
well i think there's a couple reasons
one there's conditions that are in these
countries that
we have not done enough to help improve
and that's why there is funding in the
president's immigration bill and why one
of the reasons we're eager to
have it passed we don't feel that
sending unaccompanied minors kids back
to take a dangerous journey
is the right step to take and that's not
something that we're going to do in his
administration and it won't be our
policy
but we always need to keep communicating
more effectively about how this is a
dangerous time to travel
this is a dangerous time for families to
come for children to come
and we'll continue to work to do that
more and when the
president had half a dozen republican
lawmakers in the oval office yesterday
they came out
they shared they thought it was a good
meeting but they said the culver 19
rescue package never came up why not
well did they raise the coven 19 rescue
package i don't
the president says that he makes it a
top priority
he talks about it with great urgency
uh he could have brought it up and i'm
just curious well the meeting was about
a supply chain executive order something
that there is a great deal of interest
on
and bipartisan support for the only time
the president talks about the american
rescue plan is not in meetings in the
oval office
he picks up his phone and calls
democrats republicans and others on a
regular basis
and i think he's used every opportunity
he has
to make the case publicly to have those
conversations and
it's probably why more than 70 percent
of the public including more the
majority of republicans support the plan
so that is not a signal that the
president has conceded he is just going
to pass
the package with democrats hardly look i
think
the president's view is that this is a
package
that will help get the pandemic under
control it will help put people back to
work
if somebody has a better idea by all
means bring it forward
we have not seen one uh this is a plan
that he remains committed to and he is
hopeful
that republicans many in congress will
follow what their constituents want
and the american people clearly want
this rescue plan passed they clearly
want money for vaccinations they clearly
want
schools to reopen and funding to reopen
schools and they clearly want direct
checks
so hopefully members will listen to that
and we have plenty of time for
republicans to
vote for the package thank you everyone
you